Hello, I’m sternly Andrew Heaton
and you’re militantly watching Mostly Weekly.
At ease.
Today I’d like to brief you on a little
thing called Defense Spending.
Actually, calling it a ‘little thing’
is fantastically misleading.
It’s actually the biggest thing.
The U.S. has the most powerful military in
the world.
In the 20th Century it defeated Germany twice,
Korea kind-of, and Vietnam not-so-much.
It’s the greatest force in the history of
marching band music.
That said, we’re paying way, way more than
we need to.
How much do we pay?
Come on.
There are tank treads that cost more than
that.
Fifty million?
My god, do you know how much these things cost?
A billion.
Okay I can work with that.
Multiply that by 20.
Right, okay, now multiply that by 20.
Great, now add another $200 billion for good measure.
Yes, What the Financial, indeed.
We spend Aabout $600 billion dollars a year
on the military,
and it’s set to go up to almost $700 billion
next year.
That’s almost one whole Turkey
or 30 billion turkeys!
To put things in perspective,
our defense budget is bigger than the next
eight largest world powers combined.
It’s hard to wrap your mind around just
how big $600 billion dollars is.
Let’s say that we cut the defense budget
in half, to $300 billion.
It would still be 4 times larger than Russia’s.
And the money left over would be enough to:
Buy every single American two ipads.
Or send a manned mission to Mars.
Or build a moon colony with its own Cracker
Barrel.
Or send everyone in America a check for $900,
except Kevin.
So how did our military get so expensive?
Through the Military-Industrial Complex
first brought to our attention by whiney,
limp-wristed, beta-male snowflake
Dwight Eisenhower here’s how it works.
Defense contractors make money by selling
tanks, planes,
and other killy things to the military.
They make money regardless of whether or not
we need those tanks, planes or killy things,
or if they even work.
So, they send legions of lobbyists to Washington
to convince Congress to buy the M-1-this,
the F-44-that or, my favorite,
the V-3 Smellicopter.
Meanwhile, Congress loves splurging on defense.
Contractors provide jobs in their districts,
which gets them re-elected.
A lot of the time the Pentagon doesn’t even
want certain weapons,
but Congress appropriates the budget for them
anyway.
It asked Congress to quit spending money on
Super Hornet aircrafts,
and it’s said a quarter of our bases serve
no military purpose whatsoever.
Nevertheless, Congress keeps appropriating
funds.
Republicans are constantly yammering about
the budget,
but if it involves a drone, a plane or killy
thing,
they toss money at it like it’s a naked
lady doing a naked lady dance
at a naked lady dance place.
It’s like if you’re buying a battleship
it magically doesn’t add to the debt.
So two plus two is four,
but if there's a tank it weighs down the number
weight
so it's actually three.
Even Bernie Sanders supports the F-35 jet
program
and fought tooth and nail to get it to Vermont.
Now, you might point out that if we’re not
safe, it doesn’t matter how good our economy is.
And I agree.
In fact, one of the government’s actual
responsibilities
is to provide for our common defense.
But, the budget is still subject to diminishing
returns.
For example, Russia spends about ten times
less than we do on defense.
Does anybody really think Russia is at risk
of getting invaded?
Of course not.
Ditto America.
Plus, we’ve got a salty moat on either side
of our country
and friendly neighbors to the north and south.
Our biggest threats right now are terrorists,
Kevin Spacey, and sharks.
We spend 150 billion dollars a year to maintain
the 800 military bases in eighty other countries.
At the end of the Cold War we were only in
40.
We have 200,000 active troops in more than
170 countries.
So if our biggest wars are over, why are we
deployed so heavily?
Particularly in countries with trace amounts
of shark or Kevin Spacey.
Those bases give insurgents something to rally
around and recruit with.
And we pay a lot of money to stay in Fillintheblankistan,
even though the Fillintheblankestanis hate
us.
Listen, I’m not anti-military.
I have camo pajamas.
I lost my virginity while watching “Patton.”
But at some point, defending the nation just
turns into crony capitalism with killy things.
Squandering money for the sake of squandering
money isn’t patriotic.
And it needs to be s-